this is the hand that rocks the Mabel
love that title I uh I gotta admit with
that ending and he's like you'll see it
close but and it's a number two book I
like screamed like a little girl this is
the episode that made me gasp I own home
I have the book the book closes it it
says the number two at the hand and I
just want just started bursting out
that's where I'm like I can't stop this
is like my new loss that hopefully has a
good ending but even if it doesn't like
the characters and everything else is so
good I don't care I can't even watch it
twice I don't know how you could have
and then thing to this as bad as lost
but no no exactly I mean even they're
just like again even it's JJ Abrams say
you know you you know what that
wasn't fun right I'll still watch the
show again um you know with lost it's
like okay I know the twist at the end of
each episode okay what's it adding up to
it's like that's about it you know it's
everything else is serving so hopefully
that was like this was just so good okay
so this is the introduction of Gideon uh
the child psychic again being advertised
even before even before he was
introduced and creeper ya know a great
character a great villain uh he comes up
a couple times and it's just very funny
oh sweet seven voice yeah he's he's not
really funny and menacing yes I said I
get the feeling they're trying to spoof
that whole evangelical healer thing
without actually having to piss off
Christians cuz everything about him says
that except for the fact that he's a
psychic well no but the psychic know the
bad sue images too and that were
obviously I guess is this the bad suit
the white hair the little American flag
pin
ya know I mean it's kind of really hot
time shakur all that yeah i yeah he's so
weird
um the cuz so yeah this child psychic
comes into town obviously a sham which
is hilarious we find out he has real
power so he doesn't have to create these
awards III like how um I like how he
called it - he's like Oh grunkle Stan's
just upset because this guy's an even
bigger fraud than
yes um so he it finds Mabel falls in
love with her he's trying to go out on
dates Mabel you know feeds into it just
the kind of be nice he's trying to break
it off but he keeps doing all this
really big impressive stuff to win her
over so tries to have dipper break up
with him for her um but he takes it the
wrong way tries to kill dipper Mabel
comes in does the right thing breaks up
and proper saves dipper and I love the
wanton violence in the show these kids
nearly end up dead by the episode and
it's just so casually this eyes about to
get cut in half by flying scissors and
Stan is about to make a deal with the
parents but uh
Gideon decides you two want to now and
but he will get his way and he closes
the book and it has it's the same point
that there's a two on it um so I get
just a great holy ship mom and you one
of my favorites of the show the only one
that rivaled it uh possibly is in the
season finale um but yeah I mean shut up
shut up I won't give it away but yeah I
know that this was definitely like the
big moment for me so I'm wondering how
many books are that I mean there has
rights least three at least three so um
but what if there's what if there's ten
what if there's a hunger a million yeah
it's like you don't know um so what
salmon so and it's great because you won
yeah he had the little amulet thing but
you wouldn't predict he would you know
have another book you have access to
another bug and anther even was another
book um so a great set just brilliant
set up a couple of things I noticed
watching it uh the symbol that the star
with the eye in it looks kind of similar
to something else um I have no idea what
your time yeah well um so I did I will
go more into that but the fact that
Gideon um even in the commercials like
are you tired of other you know
attractions that are lame and you show
the mystery shack again very much
building up even before he knows Mabel
even before that he wants to he doesn't
like the mystery shack and he wants to
put them out business for some reason uh
which is something again why five actors
I'm like oh
just it wants Mabel that's what it comes
down to and he wants to get revenge and
stuff but even before that yet you in
the commercial before even that Mabel he
wants to get rid of that place well he's
got another book so he's must have some
reason exactly so again it's a clever
setup um you see what else I am writing
these down um let's see
dumb little thing I love how his cave
had the exact same freckles
ah - oh that's a dumb little thing but
it made me laugh no free pizza uh that
was was gonna bring up uh that I
actually was raw that was my big shock
twist whatever is that the guy that
always wears the free pizza shirt he
didn't wear it this time I know he wears
another time though I swear to God
um I do like the continuity like talking
to voter hey sorry I nearly got you like
framed for murder under the bridge um
the they go to a place called the club
and it has a lot of red curtains and you
know a bunch of clubs from the cards
there I'm wondering that's a Twin Peaks
reference cuz whenever they had a dream
wasn't always on the card red curtains
and stuff I'm sorry I didn't even think
about and uh you know we're little
person I forget was a kid or not
could be I just seen a show in a while
but it could because there's a lot of
references to shows these people grow
try the pie um yeah so I feel wonder if
he's al Faqih said that but would be all
arias no I don't and the only other
thing I noticed that like I never
noticed before and I Pompey Stan
hesitant he has a tattoo on his back
they can't quite see if there is a
little arrow it looks like a circle
the only seal after he hangs up the
picture he Wow doll okay it's great they
steals the picture but when you cut to
him hanging it up and then could you
like ever identify something about that
edit was perfect uh cuz you try and stop
me suckas um so yeah so I'm wondering
that tattoo leads into anything
um but yeah aside from that I like I
think I see a good moral for this one uh
I mean I personally never bail situation
creepy psychics one more that um more
that it's kind of like if you're dating
someone that's really nice but you
you know or treat us of a net but it's
like they're just not for you it's like
don't don't try to convince yourself if
it's really not the one you know now
some courses like the pretty crazy and
do your own dirty work
yeah we're friend brothers sibling or
ever could end up hanging by magic and
with being eviscerated by you know lamb
shish and that's what kills you
Tuesday's products we're so stupid
Gideon lamp
Gideon lamb shares was that there was
another one to badness it's like who why
would you oh the Gideon blunt object
yeah that was funny too um yeah I'm so
important lesson yeah but but it is I
mean if both of those is do your own
dirty work
you know finesse we're gonna break out
being a breakup uh but also um yeah cuz
there are people it's like someone can
be perfectly nice and really reasonable
stuff but it's like not the person for
you and you want to go on too long then
you don't know you just have a lot they
might have yeah and they could have a
second book yeah you don't know um the
other thing I'll say uh that I really
notice in the show a lot of particularly
like anime shows and kid shows where
they have siblings um like once a while
they'll have an episode that reminds oh
yeah these two are siblings you know
like they talk about sibling stuff but
it's like you know maybe once every five
or six episodes and stuff these two
constantly feel like brother and sister
and they constantly reinforce oh yeah
absolutely the way they hit each other
the way to make jokes and they say the
same thing since it's not like hey
sometimes you need a reminder that the
brother or sister like watch you know
yeah I mean it's it's obvious that
pretty sure it is separated um that one
of them adopted separate one of them oh
you were the adopted one I already
called it first so the joke has to go
but I attached a together that's real I
what you know maybe we should watch the
next episode
not to you do in our girly scream
seriously what is this evidence